planschen im pool von nachbarn und das
in einem ganz besonderen outfit
dieser mann ist nicht wiederzuerkennen
ex-fußballmanager reiner calmund hat
sagenhafte 53 kilo abgenommen
mit einem kampfgewicht von etwa 170
kannte man kann die bisher im januar
ließ sich der 71-jährige dann einen
magenbypass leben zwei wochen später
berichtete kali dann ins studio und war
seiner operation die kinos kamen
mehr und dann hat das auch unternehmen
gedrückt man muss an dann hatte ich doch
schon erhebliche probleme mich so zu
bewegen wie ich es gerne wollte ich war
also kein google blitz mehr sondern
dicke wolke die sich dann auch nicht im
alltag des lebens so bewegen konnte wie
ich mir das vom kopf her vorstellt hat
der ex bayer leverkusen manager wurde
nach weniger strikt bypass methode
operiert dabei werden rund 85 prozent
des magens abgebunden aber nicht aus dem
körper entfernt so nimmst das marken
stück nicht mehr an der verdauung teil
70 prozent des übergewichts kann man
wohl mit dieser methode verloren und
jetzt ist mehr reiner calmund live
zugeschaltet hallo herr calmund
hallo wie hat sich denn ihr leben
verändert nachdem sie jetzt 53 kilo
abgenommen haben
ja ich sag mal ich fühle mich
federleicht wird zwar ein bisschen blöd
an aber ist so ich hätte vor der op also
mit 180 später direkt hatte dann so eine
flüssigkeit phase drei phase bitte ob er
sich dann eben 172 53 kilo weg da muss
wenn man so einen zentner weniger aus
der bade war nach hause im bett und ich
kann jetzt mit adoptions dort mit meiner
jüngsten prinzessin schön federball
spielen spazierengehen früher kriegte
ich bei meinem grossnig nach 50 kilo
mehr frieden appartement was eben noch
so ich hatte immer das glück gute werte
zu haben noch mehr blut mit blutdruck-
und jungen alles was es da gibt und die
noch besser die sind gigantisch gut
fantastisch und so fühle ich mich auch
sehr schön sie wollen aber noch weiter
abnehmen haben wir gerade eben im
beitrag gehört wie wollen sie das machen
ja vor der op hat mir der professor
onkel hatte ich vorher noch nie so genau
wie ein professor karajica wochen vorher
aus münchen aus der uniklinik ab einem
gewissen alter kann man den jojo nicht
mehr die chance mit joey kelly 30 kilo
abgenommen dann die wieder drauf denn
geschickt mehr machst du bist du dich
nicht konsequent genug und dann gesagt
keine chance sie können selbst nach
grönland auswandern
dann wird das alles medizinisch und
wissenschaftlich belegt sie können nicht
gewinnen
und jetzt habe ich mich operieren lassen
und das ist muss ich hier so reversal es
war einfach goldrichtig aber der
professor hat mir vorher gesagt mit
diesem marken band wert ungefähr
zwischen 50 und 70 kilo abnehmen ich bin
ja schon richtung 60 60 bestimmt nicht
mit jedoch langsamer ich spüre mit 70
kilo weniger zu 100 kilo schwere
modellathlet werden wir dann noch voll
zufrieden denn jetzt komplett gesund
oder naschen sie auch ab und zu noch mal
ja ich muss sagen dass ich habe nach wie
vor mein appetit
ab nächster woche können sie mich auch
sechsmal da sehen grill den adams la
vida und mir schmeckt aber es ist
natürlich klar durchschnitt morgen waren
durch die verkleinerung des magens bin
ich schneller satt aber ich sage ihnen
ganz ehrlich im vertrauen wird ohne
minarett wird man stück kuchen erst wird
der normalen heiss gegessen und trotzdem
nehme ich aber seit entscheidende ist
ich ernähre mich trotzdem wie sich
gesund ich nehme habe ohne zu hungern
und das liegt natürlich vorrangig
natürlich an der ja wie sonderbaren
verkleinerung du bist einfach früher
satt und ist wesentlich weniger habe ich
auch schon mal bisschen sündige
natürlich dazu meinem leben und auf den
puls und auch jetzt da wirken sie
richtig fröhlich gut gelaunt liegt das
auch an der magen op ja natürlich sicher
ist die marken opel jetzt über 50 kilo
weniger ich habe das hier sagt ich kann
dann tue dinge geachtet geradezu fährt
die macht ich da früher war ich als war
aus oder nie fährt dann eben an
jetzt bin ich jetzt nicht so ein
modellathlet aber netter beweglicher
fixateur der auch jetzt sich mehr mit
der eigenen jungen tochter auch so
sportlich schwimmen federball
spazierengehen bewegen kann das tut ja
gut und werde ich auch merke ich bin
also als das sagt noch klarer in der
turning worden also wenn die kilos
abnehmen die werte die bei mir schon gut
verlor azteca mops jetzt noch ich würde
so ein cholesterin wird es bei mir unter
100 und 200 ist schon gutes beispiel
und eben morgen jeden abend ich bin ja
70 oder 71 risikopatienten wird
blutdruck gemessen
sauerstoff puls alles mögliche was es
gibt fieber und morgens und abends
fantastisch vielen dank
keiner kann wir wünschen ihnen alles
gute und viel erfolg bei der weiteren
aber ich kann jedem raten wenn er die
kilos zuviel eben zu fachärzten und ran
an das messer zu verkleinern ist
wunderbar das ist nichts vermisst
dankeschön